they do a build something like this  without a back door in case it collapse  right never never there's got to be  something else look around everybody  look around what are we looking for I  don't know but is that because that's  something yeah yes George what is it  calm down sir excuse me that's a ma'am  oh you guys seem like two classy ladies  where's your name precious shantipur  where your real name precious yeah but  like when you were barn wooded you're  not your gang name or your stripper name  yeah precious hey Mikey remember that  thing you say when we were kids and even  promise never to say anything forget  about that still got one in the tank  I've been hauling it in frequent guys we  need to hire these bonds or industrial  grade they're nearly indestructible not  against Metro flats they're not that's  not what I'm saying Oh